>> Doug: IT IS DAY FIVE OF THE
PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN OVER
BORDER WALL FUNDING ON BOTH
SIDES ARE REFUSING TO BUDGE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOT BACKING
DOWN.
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
JUST HOURS AGO IN IRAQ.
>> HOW LONG DO YOU THINK THE
SHUTDOWN WILL LAST,
MR. PRESIDENT?
>> WHATEVER IT TAKES.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A WALL.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE SAFETY.
WE NEED SAFETY FROM OUR COUNTRY.
EVEN FROM THE STANDPOINT, WE
HAVE TERRORISTS COMING INTO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
CAN WE HAVE DRONES, TECHNOLOGY?
TECHNOLOGY IS BELLS AND
WHISTLES.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A WALL.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PROTECTION.
WHEN YOU SAY HOW LONG IS IT
GOING TO TAKE?
WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO SAY WE
NEED BORDER SECURITY?
WHEN ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING TO
SAY?
DON'T FORGET.
THE DEMOCRATS ALL AGREE THAT YOU
NEED A WALL UNTIL I WANTED IT.
>> Doug: HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER, SOON TO BE SPEAKER,
NANCY PELOSI IS PUSHING BACK
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT, CLAIMING
"HE'S USING SCARE TACTICS THAT
ARE NOT EVIDENCE-BASED AND IT'S
WRONG."
FORMER ACTING I.C.E. DIRECTOR
THOMAS HOMAN IS RESPONDING TO
PELOSI BY SAYING SHE'S THE ONE
WHO HAS IT ALL WRONG.
>> SHE'S 100% WRONG.
LET ME EDUCATE MS. PELOSI.
AS FAR AS CRIME, AND ACROSS THE
BORDER, I.C.E. ARRESTED 138,000
CRIMINALS LAST YEAR.
THESE ARE PEOPLE ENTERING THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AND COMMITTING
CRIMES AGAINST THE CITIZENS.
>> WHAT KIND OF CRIME?
>> HOMICIDE, WEAPONS VIOLATIONS,
ALMOST 12,000 SEXUAL ASSAULT
CRIMES.
CRIME DOES COME ACROSS THE
BORDER.
>> Doug: MY TAKE ON THIS IS
IT'S A HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
BOTH SIDES ARE DUG IN ON
POSITIONS I THINK DON'T MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE FOR THE COUNTRY AND
INDEED EVEN THEIR POLITICAL
POSITIONS.
WOULDN'T IT MAKE SENSE TO DO A
WALL, ENHANCE BORDER SECURITY, A
FENCE, AS THE PRESIDENT TALKED
ABOUT, IN EXCHANGE FOR A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR THE DREAMERS AND
SOME RIGHT FOR THOSE TEN OR
11 MILLION PURELY LEGALLY.
DOESN'T IT MAKE SENSE, DANA?
>> Dana: I THINK SO BUT I WANT
TO DEFER TO KATIE WHO WAS THERE
FOR THAT INTERVIEW THIS MORNING.
WE TALK ABOUT COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM FOR YEARS.
THREE DIFFERENT PRESIDENTS.
>> Doug: IT DOESN'T MAKE IT
WRONG.
>> Dana: I AGREE.
>> Katie: IT'S TOO BIG OF A
PROJECT TO DO WHEN YOU HAVE A
SERIOUS CRISIS AT THE BORDER AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
BORDER SECURITY IS DIFFERENT
THAN AMNESTY FOR MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE EITHER HERE
ILLEGALLY OR HER WILL BROUGHT
THEIR CHILDREN OVER WHEN THEY
WERE CHILDREN WITHOUT HAVING
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESSF
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESSR
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESSC
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESST
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESSZ
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESSN
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESSH
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESSP
GONE THROUGH THE PROPER PROCESS.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT
WANTING A WALL OR BARRIER, HE'S
CORRECT WHEN HE SAYS THAT WHERE
WE BUILT THESE THINGS IN YUMA,
ARIZONA, FOR EXAMPLE, PLACES IN
EL PASO AND SAN DIEGO, THE
TRAFFIC THERE HAS STOPPED.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT THAT IS BRINGING THESE
CHILDREN AND PEOPLE UP THROUGH
MEXICO AND USING THEM AS HUMAN
SHIELDS TO GET INTO THE COUNTRY,
YOU HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
REAL ISSUE OF THE LOBBYING
CHANGE THERE.
I'VE ALWAYS SAID THAT OPEN
BORDERS ARE INHUMANE BORDERS.
YOU HAVE THE REPORT TODAY OF THE
SECOND CHILD DYING WELL AND
BORDER PATROL CUSTODY.
THAT'S NOT A RESULT OF BORDER
PATROL.
THAT'S A RESULT OF A SICK KID
SHOWING UP AT THE BORDER AND THE
UNITED STATES GIVING THEM CARE
THAT THEY HAVE NOT SEEN FOR
2,000 MILES ALONG THE JOURNEY.
WHICH COMPLICATES THINGS
ENORMOUSLY WHEN YOU THROW IN
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION REFORM
WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
SOLVE A PROBLEM THAT IS AN
EMERGENCY RIGHT NOW.
>> Lawrence: I AGREE WITH
KATIE BUT I THINK YOU ARE AN
OPTIMIST.
>> Doug: I TRIED.
>> Lawrence: YOU ARE NOT WHERE
YOUR PARTY IS.
>> Doug: I KNOW.
>> Lawrence: AS IT RELATES TO
YOUR PARTY, IT HAS BECOME AN
OPEN BORDER PARTY.
THEY HAVE GONE FROM WANTING TO
BAN I.C.E.
LET ME SAY THAT PRESIDENT TRIED
TO MOVE ON THIS LAST WEEK AND HE
GOT MAJOR BLOWBACK.
I SAID IT LAST WEEK.
THE PRESIDENT, IF HE WANTS TO
LOSE HIS BASE, THIS WAS THE
MOMENT HE WAS GOING TO LOSE HIS
BASE BECAUSE HE WAS CAVING.
NOW THERE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION TO SAY I
CAN'T BUDGE ON THIS.
I TRIED TO GO WITH MY PEOPLE ON
THIS.
I TRIED TO GET SOME TYPE OF
REASONABLE APPROACH.
THEY ARE NOT HAVING IT.
DEMOCRATS, YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE ME
SOME WIGGLE ROOM.
WHAT YOU WANT TO PUT ON THE
TABLE IS LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT
DACA.
IT DOESN'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM AND
WE WENT THROUGH THIS WITH
RONALD REAGAN WHERE WE GAVE
AMNESTY AND SAID YOU'RE GOING TO
GET BORDER SECURITY AND IT NEVER
CAME.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AREN'T GOING
TO GO FOR IT.
>> Doug: TOM, , AND MY OFF-BASE?
>> Tom: WHERE YOU WERE
OFF-BASE WAS ADDING 10 OR
11 MILLION.
IF HE WANTS TO THROW DACA INTO A
DEAL, I THINK PEOPLE WOULD GO
FOR IT BUT THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
GO ABROAD AMNESTY.
>> Doug: THE DEAL IN 2013
INCLUDED THE 10 OR 11 MILLION
AND GOT 68 VOTES IN THE SENATE.
>> Katie: DACA IS MORE
COMPLICATED THAN JUST GIVING
CITIZENSHIP TO PEOPLE BROUGHT
HERE FROM CHILDREN FROM MEXICO
OR CENTRAL AMERICA.
THE QUESTION IS IF THEIR PARENTS
ARE STILL IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, DO THEY GET TO STAY?
IT'S A COMPLICATED ISSUE OF
FAMILY UNITS.
IT'S NOT A SIMPLE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
THERE ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING HOW TO GET STUCK.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PRESIDENT
AND WHAT THEY'VE OFFERED,
INCOMING CHIEF OF STAFF MICK
MULVANEY WAS ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY
AND HE SAID THEY HAVEN'T COME
DOWN FROM 5.7 BILLION.
THEY DID NOT SAY WHAT THE NUMBER
WAS.
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE HOPING,
WELCOME TO SOME CENTER WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FUNDING.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MAYBE
$3 BILLION HERE.
FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
>> Doug: I THINK WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT FUNDAMENTAL
POLITICAL POSITIONING.
>> Lawrence: THEY DON'T LIKE
THE OPTICS OF THE WALL.
>> Doug: I AGREE.
>> Lawrence: WE KNOW WE ARE
NOT GOING TO JUST GET A PHYSICAL
WALL IN ALL ASPECTS OF THE
BORDER.
THEY HAVE CALLED IT THE BORDER
WALL SYSTEM.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT ADDING
TECHNOLOGY TO IT.
THE SYMBOLIC MEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT HAVING AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT WHEN IT COMES TO
THE WALL ARE WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
AGAINST.
>> Doug: I AM SAYING THAT'S
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE HAS TO BE A COMPROMISE
AROUND A FENCE, ENHANCE BORDER
SECURITY, AND SOME PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR DACA RESIDENTS,
NOTWITHSTANDING THE ISSUES --
>> Lawrence: IT'S A SEPARATE
ISSUE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY DEMOCRATS
KEEP LUMPING IT TOGETHER.
THERE'S BORDER SECURITY AND THEN
THERE'S TAKING CARE OF THE
PEOPLE ALREADY HERE.
FIXING A PROBLEM WITH THE KIDS
THAT ARE HERE THAT HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE BORDER.
>> Doug: YOU CAN.
>> Katie: I THINK IF BARACK
OBAMA WOULD HAVE DECIDED TO
BUILD A WALL TO STOP AND AN
INFLUX, DEMOCRATS WOULD'VE GONE
FOR IT.
>> Dana: THEY SHOULD HAMMER
THAT A LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE
THE DEMOCRATS DID VOTE FOR
BORDER SECURITY, FENCING, THINGS
THAT LOOK LIKE A WALL.
IT'S NOT JUST THE SYMBOLISM OF
THE WALL.
A LOT OF IT IS POLITICAL
SYMBOLISM.
THE SHUTDOWN SO FAR HAS BEEN A
LITTLE BIT SYMBOLIC.
IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE 900,000
BEING FURLOUGHED, THAT'S A BIG
DEAL TO YOU.
I HOPE THEY CAN TAKE COMFORT IN
THE FACT THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS
DONE BACKPAY FOR THEM.
THE FIRST REAL DAY OF THE
SHUTDOWN IS ACTUALLY TODAY, BUT
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT GAVE
CHRISTMAS EVE AS A HOLIDAY AS
WELL.
WE WILL SEE WHAT SORT OF PAIN
COMES, BUT I THINK THEY END UP
AT 3.3 BILLION.
>> Doug: ISN'T IT RIDICULOUS,
THE WHOLE THING?
THE SHUTDOWN, THE FIGHT, ISN'T
IT THE WORST?
>> Tom: I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
I TOLD THINK IT'S FAIR FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO THROW A TEMPER
TANTRUM TO GIVE ME YOUR
5 BILLION ARE KNOCKING TO GET